trump advisor jason miller was on fox
over the weekend
and he announced that trump is working
on
building his own social media platform
so big big news there
let's listen to that donald trump
obviously has been booted off twitter
and facebook and instagram which were a
great megaphone for him does he plan
to try to get back on social media
perhaps with some new outfit
you know harry this is really
interesting the fact that the
president's been off of social media for
a while because
his press releases his statements have
actually been getting almost more play
than he ever did on twitter before
i'm not sure if that's because the
length of them are a bit longer i even
had
one reporter say that she thought it was
much more elegant
the way that the president was able to
communicate his thoughts and very much
looked more presidential in that longer
form
but uh i do think that we're going to
see president trump returning
to social media and probably about two
or three months here with his
own platform and this is something i
think will be the
the hottest ticket in social media it's
going to completely redefine the game
and everybody is going to be waiting and
watching to see what exactly president
trump does but it will be his own
platform
well we'll see that's an interesting
idea uh i'm i
i will admit that i'm of course you come
to me to be the the naysayer so
doing a little naysaying here i'm very
skeptical of this idea we'll see if it
actually happens
but in order to have a successful
run at starting your own social media
platform if you want it to be
you know big if you want it to be a a
major factor as we just heard from jason
miller
a couple of things number one trump is
going to have to
uh delegate what does donald trump
really know about starting a
social media company he's successful in
using social media it doesn't mean that
you know
anything behind the scenes to to
actually operate this on your own which
and that's fine so you got to delegate
you got to find people who know this
stuff
and who you can trust and
and and let them do it
but delegating responsibility finding
good candidates for a job
delegating responsibility that has not
proven to be one of donald trump's
strong suits that's my first issue
second issue is that we know with trump
part of his branding is like he likes to
put his name on everything he does
if it's a hotel he's starting it's a
trump hotel if it's stakes that he's
has his own line of stakes they're trump
stakes whatever it is he puts trump on
it
and yeah you could start he could start
uh whatever
trump social media side and call it
trump
or call it mega or something and uh you
you're probably guaranteed to get like
10 or 20 million users and you could
have a successful little operation that
way
but twitter has 160 170 million users
facebook has billions of users
so if you want to be major and you want
to make a play
to get into that category and you want
to make a serious dent
in twitter and facebook and take a lot
of take a huge chunk of their
users then it can't be the trump social
media platform it has to be
just a regular social media platform
that trump is
helping to run behind the scenes
but if it's a trump branded thing then
you're only going to get
trump die hards on it and there are a
lot of them but not enough to
be the next twitter or anything close to
that
so we'll see listen hit that subscribe
button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated